I also wanted to mention we have a
mutual friend in John mullaney oh yeah
oh I'm a door I just adore I think he's
a brilliant uh brilliant mind and uh
just thrilled to know him how did you
and John Mulaney come to be friendly
through uh the through the director of
Here Lies Love Alex Timbers he's a
theater director and
he directed a thing that
John Mulaney and Nick hold called
oh oh hello oh yeah I've seen that show
I love that show yeah he directed that
and said David
they'd like to sometimes invite someone
up on stage will you let them do that I
said oh sure
uh so I did I was one of the kind of
Ringers in the audience that they bring
up and they you become part of one of
the was it the tuna sandwich yeah the
tuna sandwich thing and uh they do that
and of course they're all in like uh
wigs and Prosthetics Prosthetics and all
kinds of stuff so
I have to say that I I got a little
confused
[Music]
which one's John which one which one's
Nick which is John yes no it was a
surreal moment of my life too which is a
really I mean it's a very it was a
really funny show those are both
brilliant guys and then the same thing
they heard I was in town they said would
you come and be the the uh the stooge
that sits in the audience and gets
called up so I got called up and it oh
they're both weren't dressed as these
old men they're obsessed with Steely Dan
and it is the most specific kind of
comedy and then of course it all there's
this bit that they want you to
participate in where they lure you into
mentioning this tuna sandwich and
wouldn't you like some of this tuna
sandwich and I it is one of those
moments in my life anyway and there have
been many I'm sure there have been many
in yours where I leave my body and I
observe what's happening and I there's
part of me that thinks you have a very
odd life at this moment Conan you're up
on stage it's Melanie Kroll
they keep referencing Steely Dan and
they're trying you to mention tuna fish
sandwich and uh we're on a Broadway
Theater I don't understand what's
happened in my life so it sounds like
you had this similar experience I had a
very similar experience yes this giant
tuna sandwich comes down uh appears and
really the whole stage smells like tuna
fish it really does I smelled like tuna
fish for days afterwards they wouldn't
let me fly commercially for a while uh I
just I I don't I'm I'm I like that
you're good friends with John because
I'm obsessed with whatever this line is
between comedy and music I know that
there's some kind of visceral connection
between the two I've always been in
comedy but fascinated with music and
um tried to play music and been
frustrated and always thought the grass
was always greener the last kind of
show I did
I wasn't exactly stand up but there were
quite a number of Parts on the in the
show where I would just talk directly to
the audience right kind of like a
comedian would do and sometimes I got
laughs and so I got a little little tiny
taste to that I loved it but it was
terrifying yeah as a musician you have
this
a whole group of musicians and you have
the song and everything that just the
structure is it's a structure once you
get on that roller coaster structure or
whatever you want to call it boom you're
you're supported right you just ride it
right whereas if you're just standing
there if and and you're trying to make
people laugh or pay attention at least
if they don't it's like well we're in
trouble now yeah yeah I'm always I mean
I do think there is a connection in that
uh I had to do something today and
got up in front of this crowd and I
could tell it was tight and I always
think
what time has taught me is be patient
and find the rhythm of the room like
let's find the rhythm of what's
happening in this room and then I can
work with that and I imagine that it's
somewhat similar in music where you need
to where are these people now that we're
playing for and how do we connect with
them so when you find the rhythm of the
room in that way
do you then go
oh I have to completely change what I
was going to do I'm gonna I'm gonna jump
into this other thing well I a big I
Love Mistakes it's just joyous I mean I
I grew up watching Johnny Carson tell a
joke that would bomb on The Tonight Show
and I would see
his eyes kind of glim there's gleam in
his eye and then he would have
um I mean there's a there's one segment
I really loved where he told a few jokes
in a row that didn't work out well and
then he reached up and there was a
microphone hanging above his head that
was catching he wasn't Loft he was
done with the boom and he grabbed
the Boomin pulled down and said
um is this thing on is this working and
then said uh Walmart Cleanup in aisle
five into the microphone and he was
basically just calling out the fact that
his routine was not going at all well
that night and having fun with it and I
thought that's the monologue I remember
they probably got a huge laugh huge I
have a question my uh I have a friend
who often tells me
David don't laugh at your own jokes
and I've tried to
stick to that but sometimes I can't help
it
um
it'll tickle me and I'll just start
giggling at my own jokes now sometimes I
find like if I'm in front of an audience
they love that because it's whatever
breaks the fourth wall or whatever yeah
and they go they're in on it yeah uh
other times it's like
he's just having fun by himself he's
we're not included here I'm I disagree
with your friend violently whoa okay
if you were here I would fight this
person like I I don't
um
I
sometimes
I if I'm laughing at my own joke I'm the
only one laughing yes but at least
there's someone there enjoying it
so I uh uh and and people around me will
say oh Conan you're cracking yourself up
there but I'll say yes I am and I'm I'm
only on this Earth for a little time and
I'm delighted with myself at this moment
and I I don't care that none of you are
um I want to make sure that I let you go
on time because uh I know you've got you
are an important man with places to be
um but this has been a real uh Joy it's
been a joy and an honor I want to make
sure I get the word out that uh Here
Lies Love premieres July 20th we're in
previews before that right where that
means we're still getting some bugs out
of it but it's it's the full show
and
um on the night in which I come
I will show up late the show will stop
uh Spotlight will hit me and I will
slowly walk to where I'm going to be
seated standing and um and then the show
resumes that's right and we'll have some
shoes for you
[Laughter]
uh David Byrne this is like my dream
come true thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me it was fun
talk this is cool thank you